[Musique]
les
occasions sont nombreuses et elles
s'affichent partout par gourmandise ou
par habitude vous pouvez manger de tout
et autant que vous voulez mais à quel
prix 47 % des Français sont en surpoids
voient obèses maigrir un marché qui
grossit et de nombreux acteurs se
tailler leur part du gâteau le contrôle
poids il est très intéressant dans la
mesure où il va permettre d'absorber
jusqu'à 40% des graisses
des compléments alimentaires ou encore
des machines révolutionnaires un jour il
m'a dit j'ai retrouvé la femme que j'ai
épousé
c'est quand même un beau compliment
maigrir à tout prix est aussi devenu un
enjeu de santé publique
l'obésité c'est très complexe il faut la
regarder comme une maladie à part
entière
[Musique]
je vais vous présenter pour une année
d'effort je faisais exactement des
tailles 44-46 ces derniers temps et je
n'avais pas pu me séparer de mon
dressing que j'avais surnommé d'ailleurs
espoir parce que c'était du 38-40 et
j'espérais vraiment refaire cette cette
taille un jour et voilà j'y suis arrivé
à 60 ans Roselyne Mercereau a déclaré la
guerre au kilo en trop en un an elle en
a perdu 15 un changement d'apparence
provoqué par une photo qui l'a choquée
cette photo c'était le mariage de ma
fille il y a un an
et ça a été le déclic pour dire plus
jamais
parce que vous vous plaisiez pas en fait
non non
j'avais vraiment envie de retrouver la
personne que j'étais élégante souriante
dynamique mais quel est son secret si
Roselyne assure en avoir terminé avec le
trop de féculents et de sucre son
changement d'alimentation ne s'est pas
fait seul
bonjour Hélène bonjour Nathalie vous
allez bien
les vacances se sont bien passées
malgré sa blouse blanche Hélène n'est
pas médecin c'est une coach minceur
chaque semaine plus de 60 clients
passent des entretiens de 30 minutes
et le rituel commence toujours par une
pesée la différence de cette balance qui
fait une mesure par impédance métrie
c'est que l'on va connaître et repérer
les différents types de masse masse
grasse massydrique musculaire ici on
travaille sur le rééquilibrage
alimentaire plus qu'un régime l'enseigne
vous promet de changer vos habitudes de
consommation
avec une sauce tomate maison alors les
pâtes au parmesan le soir effectivement
ce n'était pas l'idéal et vous pensez à
prendre votre contrôle poids oui
le contrôle poids est l'un des nombreux
compléments alimentaires proposés à
cette cliente ravie des résultats je
suis vraiment dans une dynamique ou de
toute façon j'ai un objectif c'est le 62
peut-être même le 60 mais là je suis
remonté à fond
et si ces pilules prennent autant de
place dans son nouveau régime c'est
qu'elles font partie intégrante du
modèle économique
je gagne effectivement ma vie à travers
les compléments alimentaires que je
revends auprès de mes clients puisque
les clients ne paient que les
compléments alimentaires c'est la seule
chose qui est à leur charge puisque le
suivi est offert cette semaine merci au
revoir chaque semaine Nathalie paye un
panier moyen de 40 euros soit 160 euros
par mois et si elle atteint son objectif
en six mois elle aura déboursé près de
1000 euros
le BG 102 on le prend au petit déjeuner
le matin et au déjeuner du midi et
celui-ci le np114 en fait on le prend 20
minutes à 30 minutes avant le déjeuner
du midi et pareil le soir 20 30 minutes
avant le dîner du soir
dans la galaxie de la minceur les
compléments alimentaires rapportent gros
avec une croissance de 6% en 2021 le
secteur pèse 2,3 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
mais la perte de poids peut aller encore
plus loin ici vous ciblez directement la
zone qui vous dérange grâce à des
machines de plus en plus pointues
cette entreprise promet à ses clients de
perdre de la graisse en quelques séances
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un petit peu
moins de volume
c'est plaque feraient fondre les tissus
graisseux sur ses cuisses d'après cette
cliente la machine était incontournable
pour arriver à ses objectifs
j'avais un petit peu de d'un début de
culotte de cheval et franchement j'ai
fait trois séances de Cryo et c'est
parti quoi alors que régime et sport
j'ai essayé de faire des régimes et tout
ça s'est installé à peu près après après
55 ans quoi ça partait pas des régimes
ne font pas donc les machines je trouve
que ça ça intervient vraiment sur des
zones précises sur la silhouette quoi
bonjour
on a déjà installé la lingettes oui ça y
est mais la star des machines la voici
la cryolipolyse une sorte de liposuccion
par le froid
donc là on va descendre jusqu'à moins 5
comment vous vous sentez très bien j'ai
plus qu'à dormir bah voilà parfait
on va faire une forte aspiration 5
minutes dans le chaud et généralement
une heure dans le froid on va descendre
jusqu'à - 5 voire moins 6 voilà ça va
cristalliser les cellules et on est sur
de la destruction d'adipocytes c'est
pour de l'amincissement
isabelle est une adepte de cette
technique après le ventre elle s'attaque
à ses hanches une séance toutes les 5
semaines
moi j'ai dû payer environ 130 euros la
séance donc vous comptez sur six sept
mois ça doit faire la 7ème séance c'est
ça donc voilà le budget il évite calculé
dès que les premiers résultats arrivent
vous vous dites ça vaut le coup en fait
c'est ça c'est maintenant je dis il y a
pas de miracle si vous faites pas ce
qu'il faut à côté vous pouvez investir
tout ce que vous voulez ça marchera pas
c'est traquer les kilos en trop pour
être mieux dans sa peau et dans ses
vêtements et le quotidien de nombreux
français parfois les enjeux dépassent
ces considérations
[Musique]
à 36 ans Émilie Castro a été opérée à
l'hôpital il y a quelques semaines après
un an d'espérance
[Musique]
une chirurgie de l'obésité que l'on
appelle bypass une opération qui réduit
le volume de son estomac
c'est votre repas ça oui
déjà je serai contente parce que
à l'heure actuelle c'est pas forcément
le cas les assiettes finies j'ai du mal
à la finir
ce pacte pour la vie a des conséquences
définitives le sucre est banni les
quantités sont extrêmement limitées et
la prise de vitamine est obligatoire
en 15 jours elle est passée de 126 à 115
kg
elle a trois ans donc il va falloir lui
apprendre à faire du vélo courir
derrière je vois bien que je suis en
peine dès qu'il faut la rattraper au
cours derrière j'ai du mal et j'ai
aucune envie qu'un jour on vient de me
dire pourquoi ta maman elle est grosse
et puis mon conjoint aussi parce que
j'ai envie de vivre à ses côtés loin
j'ai pas envie de mourir d'une crise
cardiaque bêtement dans deux trois
quatre ans on sait pas ce que demain est
fait mais autant pas autant retirer les
risques qui peut y avoir l'obésité
Emilie aimerait descendre à 85 kg et
pour atteindre l'objectif de sa vie
l'opération est apparue comme la seule
solution viable et du coup ils veulent
pas s'assumer avec quand on a fait les
rendez-vous le chirurgien nous a dit que
au fait pour pouvoir perdre du poids
c'était possible avec le sport mais
qu'il aurait fallu arrêter de travailler
pendant un an et avoir un coach un coach
nutritif et un coach sportif pendant un
an et faire que ça et c'était pas
c'était pas envisageable
pour cette chirurgie remboursée par la
Sécurité Sociale emilie a dû convaincre
pendant un an une quinzaine de
spécialistes sur sa détermination et la
capacité de son corps à supporter cette
opération et le premier d'entre eux et
son chirurgien Orléanais le docteur
abomrad après les nausées ça veut partir
il faut jamais se forcer à manger
faussement et il faut manger à l'aise
donc vous y allez doucement l'essentiel
c'est de s'hydrater la seule personne
qui m'a dit que mon état n'était pas de
ma faute c'est le docteur ah bon Brad et
pour ça forcément ça crée un lien on se
dit mais sans ce docteur peut-être que
j'en serai pas là aujourd'hui j'aurais
peut-être pas pris cette décision
ce spécialiste de la chirurgie digestive
et endocrinienne est une référence
mondiale avec ses collègues ils ont
réussi à standardiser des opérations
complexes réalisées avec des robots
dernier cri et face à l'obésité le
docteur aboumra de la firme il faut
réagir vite et fort dans l'intérêt de
tous
l'obésité appelle l'hypertension
artérielle elle appelle l'apnée du
sommeil elle appelle le diabète elle
appelle les problèmes articulaires donc
tous ces pathologies là provoquent des
des
dépenses au niveau médical au niveau
santé donc l'obésité c'est un fléau
c'est un problème de santé publique le
souci c'est que
la réponse que nous on a pour contre ce
fléau elle est faible nous on opère
moins de 1% de ce qu'on peut opérer et
ce qu'on doit opérer
en 25 ans la proportion d'obèses en
France a doublé désormais 17% de la
population un indice masse corporel
supérieur à 30 soit plus de 8 millions
de personnes
en 2018 Noémie Lorrain a retiré les deux
tiers de son estomac passant de 110 à 70
kg en 4 ans
elle voit sa coach Agathe et se rajoute
même trois séances supplémentaires de
son côté
une ancienne obèse donc quand on perd
beaucoup de poids rapidement on a tout
ce qui est la peau qui perd un petit peu
de son assisté donc c'est hyper
important de justement tonifier le
muscle pour avoir un aspect plus lisse
le sport et la nouvelle addiction de
Noémie qui a pourtant conservé son
rapport compliqué avec la balance je
crois que c'est le combat de ma vie en
fait depuis que j'ai commencé à prendre
du poids donc depuis l'enfance
adolescence je montais sur la balance il
n'y avait pas autant d'impact mais après
à l'adolescence qui sait et après en
école d'aide-soignante tu vois ça a été
de plus en plus compliqué
donc oui c'est un cercle ici en fait à
Valence
malgré son objectif atteint le regard
sur son propre corps est encore
difficile
à 38 je passais dans XL à un S mais vous
voyez
les choses disgracieuses votre corps
vous verrez pas le parcours que vous
avez fait vous allez voir le petit bout
de peau qui arrive pas à se passer avec
le muscle
aujourd'hui j'aimerais faire 65 kg
mais je sais que c'est pas possible je
sais que c'est pas possible mais j'ai
envie de le faire donc dans le cerveau
bah c'est pas que
c'est pas facile
dans la course contre les kilos en trop
et difficile de fixer une ligne
d'arrivée idéale car pour maigrir à tout
prix il faut aussi avoir une stratégie
sur le long terme qui passe par
l'acceptation de soi
[Musique]